yeah hello and welcome to sur evening
susan 1966 xuejun okay let's see what I
can go here why not usually clay 93 of
it can transpose to the right here as
well yeah black n go d 5 year of b6 and
the name will serve this is of all sorts
impossible so it seems like his out form
yes some kind of hedgehog the problem is
that this shouldn't work really
so we should have four on how to do it
yeah I think visually for is correct so
let's see here
you
[Music]
it's not it's not that bad I mean not as
bad as I thought okay I'm just going to
develop him taking on c4 it seems
extremely risky after Queen D for
a six is critical yeah okay i will
probably go to a three here when going
on to deform but I actually think that
this is a good spot because I have the
idea z5 takes lightly form so c5 and
then he's going to explain I don't know
what actually that's good takes 94 looks
terrible and defiled 24 s probably worse
maybe 96
maybe it just about holds you need
somewhere called same but sometimes they
come 2496 mattel that falls em okay then
I would save each form okay then let's
go if all it takes the night see form
if we don't see a good movie takes it
really okay so 94
so between h3 he probably called g5 but
I was actually thinking that this is
pretty strong these happiness is really
hanging quite a bit a.m. and the rook of
course 1970 cannot be captured and here
where the book group cannot escape
anyway so h3g fire
and maybe I should just take it I mean
just grab some of the material so g5 has
to be done now take on g4 is not good
but I can take and take this now 496
should see five looks okay risking a
successful I wanted to say okay just
keep at him
boosh of age seven okay well I'd it
didn't make sense ready to take him
because the bishop is certainly stronger
than the night but they're just for
simplifications that really makes no
sense to take
27 okay let's prevent it check so how to
break time morning probably have to open
this up
today is got things covered
play for up to seven somehow return yes
order them to call the a for ya now this
youporn will will do the job hopefully
jack black resigns so yeah check this
opening it was one of those things where
I was pretty surprised that this was
holding a name in any sort of way but
that already looks pretty pretty pretty
bad but somehow it still hold its a hold
yeah there it is like c5 but b5 is
hanging so it wasn't all that all that
great so right here and he has to do
something about c5 you just ignored the
idea and I don't know it it looks
difficult now cash flows and let's
cold-blooded
it's a good move absolutely I mean I
must be a little bit better here with
their activity ships but true so in this
shouldn't work right now he for is best
yeah this is this is the kind of thing
that black needs them to not lose
immediately edit this work but if voice
is pretty awful no no it is it's
basically over 90 xe4 is even stronger
okay it looks good 96 check all of a
sudden okay that's very strong okay this
is just winning the exchange so it's
good it's not not as decisive and yeah
it's technically technically winning
maybe I should have taken on g6 that
would have been maybe easier because now
he had the night it is passive but it is
covering the entry square only seven no
I was Jackie shuffling around a little
bit before i went with 84 touch okay
i'll be should be 54 stronger okay now I
wanted to want it to be quick that
didn't pay that much attention to
quality yeah it is it is winning though
you cannot defend against this so with
this open King and what King be
completely safe ok guys thanks for
watching